[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero, fourth and well son, returns to his private room.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what do you think about this last day?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some bullshit, but you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I mean, really, you've kind of made a decision, but how do you feel about that?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think going as a mage will definitely be better for my character because, as I was saying earlier with him, I want to be able to combat against other forces that are not just, like, physically.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, do you have any questions that you want to ask me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Historically, or...?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's up with the Toli, actually?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I don't know much about them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the Toli are a... You know how Monmurg is a city-state, Fairwind is an island, Flotsam, Jetsam, they're islands.
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli is a city-state, and they are another prince in the principality.
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince Sikond, Sikondforth,
[SPEAKER_00]: Is a guy that's there, and the difference between them and all the other princes is they're Sewell.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, a little different, but they are kind of equivalent to the other five princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are five princes, the Toli, Fairwind, Flotsam, Jetsam, and Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then there are two Plars in the Principality that don't vote, but they're very powerful, the Plar of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which is the Duckeberghof.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Plar Westkeep, which is the Plar up north on the Hule River.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.